claude est strict on fait des bons
produits ici n'en broad ça m'était du
québec dans vos choix une campagne
publicitaire lancée en marge de la fête
nationale pour valoriser les artisans
d'ici
la société des alcools du québec fait la
promotion de ses nouveaux logos qui
permettent de repérer rapidement les
produits du québec rrq l'été du québec
dans vos choix en repérant les produits
fièrement assemblée embouteillée au
québec mais il ya un hic
cette campagne fait en sorte par exemple
que merlot importés de france mais
embouteillée ici obtient aussi sa petite
fleur de lys on est la misère à accepter
qu'un vin chilien australiens soit
classé dans produce québec
ce vigneron de l'île d'orléans est déçu
que la campagne publicitaire place sur
un même pied les vins fabriqués à partir
de raisins du québec et les vins
étrangers embouteillée ici pour nous
vingt produits du québec
il faut qu'ils soient issus minimale mal
50,85 idéalement ça pour ça issu de
raisins québécois
la saq défend sa décision en rappelant
que les vins étrangers embouteillée
localement contribuer à notre économie
il représente 3500 emplois directs et
indirects et des retombées économiques
de plus de 600 millions de dollars
la présidente des vignerons indépendants
du québec croit toutefois que cette
campagne crée d'ambiguïté chez les
consommateurs raptor se ménageant les
logos c'est pour le logo qui vont vous
aider à vous moquer ni ici ni ailleurs
c'est un bon vin de qualité qui avaient
des des publicités faites par notre
gouvernement québécois et non par la saq
louis de nos crois que la saq devrait
davantage insisté sur la valeur ajoutée
des vins conçu au québec
un vin qui produit ici prenez juste ici
sur l'île d'orléans
17 vignobles commerciaux à sa fin on a
même déjà ça fait vivre d'autres
commerces des restaurants des hôtels
donc ça crée un rapport économique assez
important dans la région
le conseil des vins du québec souhaite
que l'insécurité le nouveau logo des
produits qui sont seulement bouteiller
en province
ici marc antoine avoir radio-canada san
pedro nunes sur l'île d'orléans